eric holland will get the start for the
pirates he's had one very tough inning
and otherwise he's pitched pretty
decently this year a leadoff walk for
christian yelich putting a man aboard
well it's the only lefty in the lineup
light towers
over the first base side of foul ground
hard roller on the second glove by
frazier the second one relay two a
double play good work there you like to
see that after a lead off walk josh
lindblow yeah want to know the big
earned run average 17 and two thirds
innings he's got 28 strikeouts that's a
good news colin moran two and two two
outs
and toward right field and that is down
it's fair and stays in play cora waving
frantically to try and get frazier home
and the throw and he is
safe and the pirates lead one to nothing
now it's first and second luis rias was
one out of three last night
possibly a double play ball four six
three it is derek holland has gotten two
double play balls mark mathias
will lead things off
that's hit in the air into left center
field to the gap and that's going to get
to the wall matthias on his way to
second and a leadoff double here in the
third and here's ryan braun pirates
turning double plays in each of the
first two innings
and holland yanks the throw out into
right field trying to
check matthias and it just yanked out of
his hands and um going over to third is
matthias faces christian yelich
swinging a ground ball rolled right up
first stayed fair and bell will shovel
onto holland covering for the out he did
throw him a fastball and yell it's
grounds out to end the threat there's
one out jed jerko the batter now payoff
to jerko
and that is hit in the air to left field
he hit it a ton
and that is
out of here a home run
that was a bomb off the bat of jed
jericho a solo shot we are tied at one
not sure where it landed but that ball
was way back i mean he got all but a
pitch up and in brewers on the board
they tie it up
runner at first and manny pina come to
the plate
a bullet and
play made by riddle pina is retired now
that's a bullet that's going to be down
in the corner for a double but instead
it's just it's an out two outs now and
here's luis urias
half swing he went he knew it and
holland fastball at 94 strikes out urias
they strand garcia at second but the
brewers get the equalizer here's polanco
driven deep to right center field and
some coffee
el cafe gregory polanco's third home run
a two-run blast
as he clears the deck to give the
pirates a 3-1 lead
in the third inning but was left
stranded at third 3-1 pitch
and that is down the line and that's a
fair ball to the corner and left
and mark mathias has his second double
of the day keep this kid in the lineup
huh wow and now first and second for
christian yelich
95th pitch coming up for derrick holland
and he checked it no he did not the
offers and that is out number two
that's a big out
here was the dh last night when hitler's
in four trips
looking for his first hit here in this
series the
and
one-two
strike three call got him on the inside
corner
and derrick holland pitches out of
trouble and suitors on the pitch for the
crew facing adam frazier
drive to deep right field and out goes
frasier adam frazier
hits his fourth
greets
the lefty sooner
and gives the pirates a 4-1 lead bran
who had a two out rbi double back in the
first inning
line drive to left and yellow having
trouble can't see it it's over his head
right in the sun
line drive double for moran he never saw
it
that wasn't like he lost the ball it was
he didn't even know what area to head to
so moran at second for brian reynolds
that's crack deep to left center field
by reynolds he jumped on that pitch
stays in play he's into second base with
a double
another run in and the pirates take a
5-1 lead
here's jacob stallings
i think that they throw it firm well
that's hit well by jacob stallings
toward the wall and clear the deck
cannonball coming
jacob stallings first home run of the
season and the pirates lead it 7-1
brewers have two on with two out for
kesten
and there's a fly ball hit back into
center field deep swing for the fences
you'll find it and over it it's gone
kesten hera with the three-run shot
as the brewer is getting back into the
game here in the seventh a two-strike
three-run home run for casting hero how
about that pirates have them loaded with
two outs jacob stallings aces the rookie
drew rasmussen
not close that's what you're gonna get
with
inexperienced pitchers despite the fact
that he's one of their better prospects
he walks in a run
and the pirate's lead is now 8-4
gonzalez comes up empty
ground ball up the middle a base hit
that'll take care of that dyson and
tucker score
on the two run single by eric gonzalez
the pirates have a 10 spot on the board
and lead by six
and now adam frazier bunko has reached
base as frazier hits this one to left
field and this will bring home jacob
stallings
frazier into second with a double core
waving home a second run and he will
score as frazier gets back to second a
two run double the pirates have a dozen
and lead 12 to
here's
four
two walks two pop-ups as that breaking
ball bounces to the back stop and that
will get arcia to second
brawn sends one to the gap in left
center field deepest part of the yard
and that'll bounce over the fence for a
double rco will score
and the brewers have their fifth run of
the of the ball game they're loaded here
is chase peterson
hard hit right at second and raise the
jolly roger for a second straight game
the pirates
pound the brewers